[Musique]
elle se plante tout près d'ici elle nous
observe là en ce moment
c'est vous le rhin jeudi la police c'est
pourquoi je suis là
c'était pêche joindre au fait tu sais
quel genre de livre qu'il écrit charles
stephen king je sais ce que vous faites
qu'est ce que tu crois savoir je vais
être très clair cette rumeur du léopard
j'aimerais le voir
[Musique]
on a retrouvé le corps de yann à
langogne
son corps est greffé
de partout
[Musique]
si je suis que peu de femmes chose
pareille contrairement à toi aussi
ce que vous faites mais à l'époque je
suis rien je crois aux miracles
tu veux pas d'un mort-vivant que leur
teneur et je me lance avec vous je me
sens vivante ok
[Musique]